God says to Rachel,
two nations are in Di womb,
and two manner of people shall be separated from night bowels and one people
shall be stronger than the other,
and the elder shall serve the younger,
and so there's a inversion there,
right?
Because as we've discussed
historically speaking in traditionally speaking,
it's the elder son that to whom the disproportionate blessings flow.
There's some truth in that too.
Even more.
What would you say more empirically?
Iq tends to decrease as the number of children in the family increase the
younger.
The oldest is the smartest.
Generally speaking,
it isn't clear why that is,
but it might be that they get more attention and who knows?
So those of you who are younger can be very unhappy about that fact.
Now Jacob.
Okay,
so there's another,
there's another plot line here too,
because I'm a Abraham and and Rebecca
are at odds.
It's.
Sorry,
Isaac and Rebecca are at odds about the children.
Right?
So there's a,
there's an eda pole twist to it too because.
Well,
Isaac is allied with Esau who turns out to be the hunter type.
So he's your basic rough and tumble character,
you know,
when he's kind of a wild looking guy called Harry and he likes to be outside.
He lives in tents,
he likes to hunt.
He's a man's man.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Whereas Jacob dwells intense,
you know,
he doesn't go outside much.
He's more,
well maybe he's more introverted,
but he's certainly the sort of kid adolescent say who hangs around home and
there's some intimation that he's as,
while he's clearly as mother's favorite and with all the advantages and I
suppose disadvantaged that go along with that.
And Isaac and Rebecca don't see Iti about who should have predominance among the
sons.
And Rebecca is quite complicit with Jacob in inverting the social order.
So the first thing that happens that's crooked is that Esau comes in from
hunting and he's,
you know,
he's been out for a number of days and he's ravenous and he's kind of an
impulsive guy,
doesn't really seem to think about the longterm very much.
And Jacob was cooking some lentil stew and Esau wants some of it.
Jacob refuses and,
and then says that he'll trade his,
his birthright for it.
And uh,
Esau Greece,
which is a bad deal,
right?
It's a bad deal.
And so you,
you could say that Esau actually deserves what's to them,
although he at minimum,
you'd have to think of them both as being equally culpable.
It's a nasty trick.
And so that's Jacob's first trick.
And then
the second trick is that it's later and Isaac is old and blind and you know,
close to death and it's time for him to bestow a blessing on his sons,
which is a very important event apparently among these ancient people.
And Esau again is out hunting and Rachel dress dresses.
Jacob up in a hairy,
puts a goat skin on his arm.
So he's kind hairy like Esol and dresses.
A Minnesota was closed so he smells like Esau and
Isaac tells Esau to go out and hunt him up.
Some venison I think it is.
And uh,
which is a favorite of his.
And Rebecca has Jacob Cook up a couple of goat kids and serve that to Isaac and
play the role of Esol.
And so he does that,
it's pretty damn nasty.
Really all things considered,
you know,
to play a trick like that both on your brother and on your blind father andy in
collusion with your mother.
It's not the sort of thing that's really designed to promote lot of familial
harmony.
And so especially because you've already screwed them over in a big way once you
know,
you'd think you'd think that would be sufficient.
So anyways,
he's successful and ESL loses his father's blessing.
And so that Jacob ends up really in the position of the firstborn.
And it's quite interesting because,
you know,
God tells Rachel that Jacob is going to be the dominant twin and you'd think
again with God's blessing or at least the prophecy that Jacob would end up being
in a good guy.
But he certainly not presented that way to begin with,
which is also quite interesting given that he's the eventual founder of Israel.
And it's another indication of the realism of these old stories,
you know?
And it's,
it's quite amazing to me.
It's always been quite amazing to me how unpredictable these stories have
remained.
You know,
because you'd think that if you're even the least bit cynical,
especially if you had the kind of Marxist religion is the opiate of the masses
kind of viewpoint,
which,
which is a credible viewpoint,
you know,
although it's wrong,
but it's quite.
Well,
I think it's a shallow.
I think it's a shallow interpretation and not part of the reason I think it's a
shallow interpretation is because the stories would be a lot prettier if that
was the case.
These characters wouldn't have this strange,
realistic,
moral ambiguity about them.
You know,
if you're going to feed people a fantasy then it,
you want it to be like a harlequin novel or or,
or our greeting card or something like that.
You don't want it to be a story that's full of betrayal and deceit and murder
and mayhem and genocide and all of that.
That just doesn't seem all that.
What would you say?
Calming,
I guess would be the right,
right answer.